either way it is way past time to get
hillary back into the white house the
lady's got a speech to give
she wrote it five years ago for her
inevitable inauguration thanks to the
macedonians that didn't happen but she
never threw it away she still got the
speech
last month she read a portion of it on
nbc news watch
i dream of going up to her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
who's she crying for herself
in case you're confused by the context
there that was hillary telling her
deceased mother that is going to be okay
because hillary has been elected
president states no more tears no more
anxiety we're going to make it we've got
a woman in the white house
a lot's happened since hillary clinton
wrote those words it's a different
country now than it was five years ago
but hillary clinton hasn't changed her
primary interests remain exactly what
they always were she's still talking
with endless and undimmed enthusiasm
about herself
we don't know what's in the rest of her
victory speech we're going to have to
wait until january of 2025 to find out
but one thing we can safely assume it
ends with a cackle and a finger
jason nichols the co-host of vince and
jason save the nation along with vince
colonies he's a longtime democrat and
perfect for this conversation jason
nichols joins us now our friend great to
see you jason so hillary clinton
democrats made the case and and as noted
i think it's an entirely fair case
that it was hillary clinton's right to
be president of the united states it was
in fact your destiny in god's will it
was stolen from her by the macedonians
so why wouldn't that still be true why
doesn't she have a moral right to the
presidency in 2024
well first of all you know this is
almost like
like groundhog day if it were a horror
movie like this is such a bad idea i'm
surprised someone actually put the pen
to paper to actually say this uh number
one as you as you alluded to she's 77
years old so when people are talking
about joe biden's energy levels
she's at the same age as trump and biden
and all these people and the democrats
say that they that we want new
leadership and younger leadership the
other element of this is no one
energizes the right the way hillary
clinton does
the same thing with democrats and donald
trump when you mention donald trump now
they're having trouble messaging
because donald trump isn't on the ballot
so hillary clinton does the same thing
gets people excited on the right and
they're going to go out and vote against
her which makes it really difficult for
democrats and and the other thing that i
would say bill can't wait can i just
want one correction i you know i'm on
the right i'm innervated by hillary
clinton i'm totally exhausted just
thinking about her it's just like it's a
bottomless well of narcissism and it
sucks me in every time i start thinking
about her as much as she thinks about
herself and that's bad
but again
you will go out and vote against her i'm
almost positive
fair
the other thing that i'll say is that
you know the backbone of the of the
democratic party is african-american
women and african-american women
will be
incensed and feel betrayed if hillary
clinton comes back and jumps the line on
kamala harris and if african-american
women
even a small sliver a small percentage
sit on their hands you're not going to
win georgia you're not going to win
pennsylvania wait wait wait wait wait
wait win a lot of these things you know
you may be right
look you may be absolutely right as a
political matter i suspect that you are
but as a moral matter
30 years ago kama harris wasn't even
willie brown's girlfriend yet i mean i
think she was
still in high school in canada no i'm
not being mean and just honest so
hillary clinton has been in this game a
long time and i do think it's fair to
say that if anyone's earned it in the
democratic party it's certainly her it
wouldn't be jumping the line exactly
would it yeah a long disgraceful career
but still long
she's had a long career she has a lot of
accomplishments and sometimes you have
to be able to walk away and say hey i
did great things you know i became
secretary of state people have to call
me secretary clinton they're going to
call me that for the rest of my career
or the rest of my life i should say uh
and move on and
the vice president of the united states
right now is kamala harris
and i think people will feel disgusted i
don't care how much hot sauce she uses
and how often she goes on the breakfast
club african-american women will feel
disgusted if she jumps the line the last
thing is that
bill clinton is a liability he took a
lot of private jet flights on
you know a couple of people's jets that
i won't say
that will come back
you know that will come back to bite him
donald trump was on those jets as well
but you know i i think you're i think
you're speaking of jeffrey epstein who
hillary clinton absolutely did not kill
and i mean that she did not
so now that we've established that i
want to thank you jason nichols for
coming on tonight it was great to see
you
hey great seeing you tucker thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else